hello John Perry here you are watching
the stated casually channel the other
day I decided to visit the beach and I
noticed that once I hit damn sand I
could feel things hitting my feet in the
air every time I took a step a close
look revealed what as a kid I used to
call sand fleas the critters that I
thought were sand fleas are more
commonly called sand hoppers and I like
that name much better because first off
they don't actually bite like fleas do
and second fleas jump with their legs
you can read all about that in this
paper from the Journal of Experimental
Biology it's open source and there is a
link to the article in the video
description so go check that out and if
you feel like it sand hoppers on the
other hand they do not use their legs to
jump instead they use a very different
depending one that completely gives away
their evolutionary history you are
watching evidence for evolution in your
own backyard beach edition the beach is
sort of close to my backyard well it's
about a 50 minute drive but close enough
cut me a little slack I didn't feel like
redoing the branding of this entire
series just because of this one episode
so Beach Edition sand hoppers are also
sometimes called sand shrimp because at
least to my untrained eye they look
exactly like tiny little shrimp and they
live in the sand so makes sense they're
actually not shrimp though they are
amphipods a large group of shrimp-like
creatures that normally live in the
ocean
telling amphipods and shrimp apart is
actually easier than you might think
you have two main options you can either
count their legs shrimp are decapod just
like crabs and lobsters and the vast
majority of species have ten legs five
on each side if you count their little
pinchers or better yet just check to see
if they have a carapace the carapace is
that long shield like structure that
extends back behind a shrimp's head
amphipods don't have a carapace shrimp
amphipod shrimp amphipod shrimp amphipod
you get the picture the reason that I
love sand hoppers aside from the obvious
fact that they are both adorable and
evil jerks to each other for apparently
no reason see what I mean
check out this guy he's gonna get kicked
in the face just for trying to be
friendly it's so heartbreaking the
reason that I love Santa hoppers is that
they are a perfect example of a modern
transitional species I mean technically
you could say that all species are
transitional humans for example evolved
from non-human Apes and I guess if all
goes well we will eventually give rise
to several new species in the future but
sand hoppers are extra transition II ish
that's a new technical term that I just
came up with they're extra transitioning
ish because they are currently
transitioning from life in the ocean to
life on dry land and that is a big big
deal usually when a sea critter washes
up on to shore it dies even many crab
species which have these nice hard
exoskeletons that are both good for
supporting their weight on land and for
holding water in even many crab species
don't do well out of water
kelp crabs like this one can sometimes
be okay if they find a nice damp place
under a rock to hide but when I found
this little guy he was he was dying
unfortunately possibly from too much
exposure to the Sun and dry air possibly
he was injured from a wave or a bird but
sadly I found him dead shortly after
taking this footage the fact that Santa
hoppers do just as well on land as in
water is remarkable very few animals are
skilled in this way but beaches and tide
pools are the perfect environments to
encourage this type of evolutionary
change the beach itself after all is a
transitional habitat you've got the
full-on water from the actual ocean you
have shallow pools you have super wet
sand you have sort of wet sand and then
you have dry sand and dunes and then
eventually you have people's backyards
when you have a nice ecological gradient
like this populations of animals can
actually get split and specie ate one
group of the population evolving towards
a more land like lifestyle and the other
maintaining its aquatic lifestyle and
that's exactly what we see happening
with these sand hoppers
biologists call this Perry Patrick
speciation a small group of a larger
population ends up going into a new
ecosystem no longer interbreed with the
old population and so the two evolve on
different trajectories as mentioned
earlier sand hoppers don't jump with
their legs instead they use their little
shrimp like tails these tails originally
evolved for swimming and they still use
them for swimming when they're playing
in the water but on land when startled
their tails just spaz out tossing the
animals upward to as high as at least
one foot in the air by my estimation for
those of you that don't like measuring
things in feet that's about thirty point
four eight centimeters this is a perfect
example of a powerfully effective
exaptation an exaptation is when an old
trait is repurposed for a new function
one for which it did not originally
evolve in this case a strong swimming
appendage the tail is used as a spring
to evade land predators and evade it
does because of the way that they jump
so fast so far and in a fairly
uncontrolled random pattern they are
extremely difficult to catch unless of
course you just dig a hole and kind of
herd them into it which I wish I had
thought of earlier because I spent about
an hour before I was finally able to
catch a single sand hopper that was
large enough to really see on camera
most of the critters I caught were only
a few millimeters long and really hard
to keep in focus after a little practice
however I discovered a sand hopper
hunting trick the bigger ones and by big
I mean there's still only about half a
centimeter long the bigger ones can only
jump about thirty times before they have
to stop and take a breather and so if
you just chased one long enough it will
eventually let you pick it up no qualms
whatsoever the hard part of course is
actually keeping track of a single
individual for 30 whole jumps they are
almost perfectly camouflaged the species
of santipura that I found in Oregon I'm
told is a mega lure chestie at
California onna they come in a variety
of colors but I only found grey inspect
unfortunately but mega Lorch STI
California Anna seems to like being on
land more
then it likes being in the water at
least that was true for the few that I
caught but they do still enjoy seawater
and they appear to need it in order to
survive because I was not able to find
any sand hoppers in the dry sand and
especially not in the dunes higher up on
the beach a quick little side note I did
however find this beautiful little
succulent blooming in the dunes
succulents normally grow in deserts the
Oregon coast is not a desert but water
falls through sand so quickly that it
might as well be so anyway during the
day sand hoppers dig burrows and hide
and they do this so that they don't get
eaten and they do it so they don't dry
out in the Sun they'll also sometimes
just hide in clumps of seaweed which is
also a source of food for them there are
a lot of predators on the beach
especially birds while organ sand
hoppers appear to be stuck at the
water's edge they still need it in order
to survive there is a species in
Australia and now thanks to
international shipping they have begun
invading parts of California there is a
species of amphipods that most people
call long shrimp why well remember when
I said that sand hoppers are a perfect
example of a transitional species on one
end of that transition we have their
fully aquatic cousins and on the other
end of that transition we have lawn
shrimp lawn shrimp are land animals they
live in leaf litter and in damp soil
like that often found in over watered
lungs if you happen to have a lawn
shrimp infestation in your own backyard
you see what I did there tied it all
together nicely
yeah if you happen to have a lawn shrimp
infestation in your own backyard and you
want to get rid of them you have two
options
option number one just let the grass dry
out for a bit they will quickly leave in
search of a slightly wetter environment
maybe your neighbor's yard for example
or option number two and this is the
evil one you can if if you want just
flood the place this works because even
the lawn shrimp clearly evolved from
beach dwelling ancestors and those beach
dwelling ancestors clearly evolved from
fully aquatic ancestors modern lawn
shrimp because
they've been living on land for so many
generations they will drown in standing
water so there you have it crystal-clear
undeniable evidence for evolution and
your own backyard beach edition so long
for now stay curious and also subscribe
to my youtube channel
I am at the tidepools at the organ code
and this is fresh water coming from a
little stream coming in to a tide pool
here what I want to show you it's really
neat the water is actually staying
separate there's fresh water on top and
salt water on the bottom and at the top
maybe five inches of fresh water
underneath that is salt water and you
can actually see
and I disturbed the wine from the fresh
water install what I didn't you see that
you see that
that is amazing just slight differences
in chemical makeup and the water doesn't
want to mix after making this
observation I spoke about it with a limb
knowledge estate old me that my
explanation for why this is happening
was actually wrong it's not the chemical
differences between salt water and fresh
water in this case that are preventing
them from mixing instead it's the
temperature difference sea water in
Oregon is extremely cold we've got a
nice cold current coming in from the
north and the fresh water in this case
was about 10 degrees warmer and we all
know that hot air rises right well the
same is true of course for water and
because the warm water is pouring in on
top of the cold water and because the
warm water is pouring in so gently it's
just not mixing it's staying on top just
sitting there floating on the colder
water below the physics here is just
fascinating